Film Courage: How does a writer create conflict?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher
and Consultant: Conflict is created by two
opposing forces. If we're talking about the main
conflict in a story, that's the protagonist trying
to pursue their goal and then whatever main
force of opposition is getting in their way.
It can manifest in a lot of different ways but
it's whatever that main thing is that's stopping
the protagonist or not allowing them to easily and
quickly achieve that goal and it seems like let's
say with Hustle movie [Netflix] which we've talked
about earlier the Adam Sandler it's a pretty clear
idea of what that conflict is. But if you look at
let's say Forrest Gump [1994] an older version of
a movie it's not actually that clear there's many
things he's encountering and that's another reason
that I would call Forrest Gump an advanced craft
story right because it's pretty non-traditional.
It's you have one guy and I don't know that I
would say he has a very clear end point that he's
working toward it's a little bit episodic we're
watching him go through history different notable
points in history and accidentally showing up
in the right place at the wrong time or whatever
so that is a that's one of those stories that I
think would be a difficult one for a newer writer
to try to make work because if you don't have that
like standard framework of character pursuing a
goal to give you that spine and that main conflict
to rely on then you have to use other tools in
your toolkit to create enough conflict and enough
engagement to keep us invested right to keep us
engaged in the story and not checking out and
turning it off so I think Forrest Gump does that
through like just the novelty of the character
right like he's what's that guy going to do next
like where is he going to show up and what what
famous moment in history are we going to show it
see him pop up in so I think that's part of the
appeal of that story and then also within within
each little segment of story I do think that
there is conflict it's not like I'm saying that
it has no conflict but I think it happens in like
instead of happening big picture across the whole
movie if I'm remembering it correctly it happens
more in self-contained segments and then you also
have these store these like longer story lines of
like his love for Jenny right his relationship for
Jenny which weaves in and out of the other stuff
that's happening if if I'm remembering that right
yeah no that's excellent and and then if you look
at crash which I know we brought up earlier that
is like nothing but conflict yeah which is the
through line of basically the story that ties all
the characters and different stories together yeah
so that one has so many I think it has like three
or four intersecting storylines right and each
one has its own main conflict that we're following
and then part of the appeal of that too is seeing
how those story lines intersect because that's
the the point of the story or the concept of it
how can goals of the protagonist and antagonists
oppose each other to create conflict well there's
a lot of different ways I think that if you look
at if you look at the movies that you like
you'll you'll probably see that they the main
conflict falls into a few different categories
it's not always the same from movie to movie
sometimes the protagonist has a goal and the
antagonist is trying to stop them sometimes
the antagonist has a goal and the protagonist
is trying to stop them sometimes they both want
the same thing and so they're competing for a
prize or a thing that only one of them can have
and then sometimes they just happen to be the
protagonist and antagonist are just two characters
who each have a goal that happen to conflict with
each other so they're getting in each other's way
those are the ones that I've noticed are
the are the most common versions of that
sure and then did we go back to bridesmaids that
there is it seems like all of them have a common
goal which is to be accepted amongst their peer
group yeah well if we're talking about the story
goal the more like plot specific thing that
the protagonist is trying to achieve so it's
actually the antagonist is Helen which is the
Rose Byrne character [Bridemaids] right and she
wants to take over our protagonist's friendship
so she's the rival for this best friendship right
that Annie our protagonist has her lifelong
best friend so when Annie discovers that
about the Helen character that's when she forms
her goal to stop the antagonist right so it's just
it's a little bit of it might sound very technical
or very like theory heavy but I think these are
just tools that help you understand your own story
and understand how your particular story works so
it's not that I'm I certainly don't mean that you
have four different types of conflict and you have
to use one of them I think if you if you've come
up with an idea that you're trying to develop
trying to look at it through these four types
of conflict right or these four like conflict
dynamics if you can see that your conflict falls
into one of those categories it just helps you
understand like oh okay so if mine is like this
then that means it gives you it gives you a little
bit of guidance in terms of okay so that means the
antagonist has to come up with their goal first so
that then the protagonist can find out about it
and form her story goal right and that gives you
a little bit of guidance in terms of like okay so
that's the order that things need to happen in so
I can break down the plot of my movie that way and
it helps you write it so right and it seems like
in some films the antagonist doesn't really turn
out to be the antagonist at all or maybe that's
just how I'm seeing it and then others it's
clearly that was the antagonist and they were
defeated or they they win whatever way so Silence
of the Lambs we know that definitely he's the
antagonist but in in Bridesmaids it's not maybe
Helen is not totally it's just that they both
had their own needs and they were just getting in
the way yeah and I think that that you can look at
that too as being like appropriate to the tone or
the style of what you're writing right because it
might have felt weird if Helen that antagonist
was had seriously like evil designs on Annie
and all that stuff right so the humor in that
keeps it that that's also a guide in terms of
like what types of conflict are going to work in
this so those two characters you probably have a
little bit more empathy for for Helen than you
do for Buffalo Bill you'd even though you learn
why he's doing what he's doing Helen is more of
a real character and the comedy comes from the
these like wacky situations that our protagonist
gets herself into sure and we look at maybe Helen
it's more about vanity and serving her own ego and
yeah but but then you find out that actually she's
very empty and so it's not it's you feel for her
in the end yeah you want to hate her and then you
realize I don't actually hate you yeah they do a
good job actually of revealing that she is not the
I mean she is shallow and and focused on status
and and all that through the movie but they do
reveal that she has a an emotional need of her own
she's lonely and she's in an unfulfilling marriage
and so you end up growing I think to at least feel
for her if not like her more by the end and she's
still the when we're talking about protagonist and
antagonists we're really just talking about like
the mechanics of the story not necessarily that
she needs to feel like a villain or like a an evil
character or even that you can't like her you can
like the character who is the antagonistic Force
we're just talking about the the way the elements
of the story work together to create that that
story engine or that that spine of the story
that we were talking about earlier I think we
spoke about this briefly in our last interview
but what are the four common ways characters
challenge protagonists oh well I usually think
about that in terms of like the supporting
characters that are around the protagonist and
again these are not not limited to four there
certainly could be many other ways but I think
that these are the patterns that I've noticed
a lot of times the supporting characters will help
the protagonist through conflict right like they
create some conflict with the protagonist but that
conflict or that pain that they're bringing into
the protagonist's life is one of those forcing
mechanisms that that force that protagonist to
grow and learn the lesson that they need to
learn right so the four that I've noticed
are like I think I call them like aspirational
models so giving your conflict or sorry giving
your protagonist a a model of what they would like
to do or like to achieve or like to be and that
can create conflict because it creates a situation
where your protagonist is unhappy with where they
are and they're striving for more there's also
the cautionary tale so creating creating it's
almost the opposite of the of the other one where
it's showing your protagonist what could happen
if they continue down the road that they're on
right so this is like that that side character in
and this is such a minor minor role but in Crazy
Stupid Love that sad divorced dad at the bar right
like that's the cautionary tale he does not want
to become that guy so he's going to continue on
striving to be the womanizer that he's being
groomed to be because it's that that cautionary
tale it's a reminder to him and then there's
also I forget what I've labeled them but
you have the Mentor character or the person that
helps your character learn that they're capable
or they have it in them to do the thing that
they're trying to do and that doesn't always
have to be a nice Mentor it can be someone who
pushes through tough love or through conflict
through challenging your character but it's but
the ultimate effect is that it's forcing them
to grow and to accept that they are strong
enough capable enough smart enough whatever
and then what's the fourth one actually oh so a
new world view oh yeah so that's challenging the
way your protagonist sees the world right so a lot
of times the transformation that your character
goes through is is a is an it starts internally
and then it manifests externally so sometimes
there's a supporting character that demonstrates
the new way of thinking that maybe ultimately your
character will adopt or it challenges their own
way of thinking enough that they grow and they
make that change that they need to make to have a
new attitude about the world or A New Perspective
a new life philosophy that that was the the
point of the story right that was the growth
that they needed at the beginning yeah so I think
in Bridesmaids is Melissa McCarthy that one scene
yeah that's so great so she gives her a kick in
the pants and and does it in a a sweet tough love
way yeah yeah that's a great scene so she comes
in and she's like what did she say it's something
like the world isn't gonna like hand it to you
you have to go out there and take it the world's
telling you it's here to be taken or something
like that I can't remember the exact words but but
yeah she she gives her that it's very funny but
it's also the exact like tough love message that
Annie needs at that point sure and she's literally
on the couch yeah not just metaphorically only
touch she's on the couch feeling sorry for herself
and she's I think she picks her up doesn't she
even throw her over her shoulder or something
but yeah and then with Hustle movie I can't
really remember I feel like there were Mentor
characters that were helping the Adam Sandler
character yeah well what's interesting I think in
Hustle movie is that you don't have to have a I
guess like archetypal Mentor for this to for this
like role to come into play any character yeah any
supporting character that helps your protagonist
along that Arc of growth right can can fill any of
these roles so what's great about Hustle movie is
those two guys it's really their relationship they
learn from each other so even though they're not
like technically what I would call like a mentor
to each other that's not their role throughout the
whole movie maybe in terms of helping each of them
grow and and get to the point that they need to
be in order to succeed in the movie they do learn
from each other like the basketball player learns
that there's some people you can rely on you can
actually depend on someone they're going to come
through for you and I forget what Adam Sandler
learns from the basketball player but it's I think
it's complementary to that right it's like if
you keep trying keep working you can like succeed
and not let people down or something like that so
talking about that Melissa McCarthy
character quick quick point about that
what's great about that character is that that
speech she gives right to Annie doesn't come out
of the blue so that was the last thing I wanted
to mention about her was that that character has
that world view from the beginning so she Melissa
McCarthy has that attitude about you go out and
you grab life you you do it you take what you
want or you take the life you want you don't sit
back you don't sit on the couch and like let it
pass you by if you want something you go out and
you try for it if you fail no big deal if you look
like a fool no big deal but you you have to try in
order to get what you want and so I think if the
bad version of that relationship and that movie
would have been if Melissa McCarthy was just a
nice bridesmaid who came along at the right moment
in the end to tell Annie what she needed to know
right that would have felt unearned and tacked on
but because we saw that we didn't know where that
was going from the beginning but we saw that that
Melissa McCarthy character was that person all the
way through so when she delivers that message to
Annie right when she needs it it makes sense it
feels emotionally true sure sure and just going
back to Hustle movie real quick it seems like
also too they both respect each other because they
know their families are very important to them
yeah and so I think they both have earned that
and they become almost mentors to each other
yeah in some ways yeah I think they do they they
because they each go into it I think with certain
preconceived notions about the other right like
our basketball player thinks that Adam Sandler is
just this rich American who can like he's got the
the wallet of the team behind him and he can do
whatever and over time they learn they learn how
desperate each one is but they learn what's really
motivating each of them and they bond over that
right because they each have a family to like you
said each have a family to support they learn that
they each are like on their this is this is it
this is is the last chance that they have to like
make this big thing happen so as those truths are
revealed about each of them it bonds them it makes
them grow closer which helps that like partnership
and help helps them accomplish the thing yeah.